Melissa would need six hours to edit the film and Carlos would only need four
hours. Great thinking if you found these two answers. We'll start solving this
equation by multiplying through by the LCD two and 4 tenths times x times x
plus 2. The product of these three denominators. When we multiply through by
the LCD, we can simplify each of the terms. The first term reduces to two and
four tenths times x plus two. The second term reduces to two and four tenths
times x And the last term simply reduces to x times x plus 2. We distribute 2
and 4 10ths to get these two terms, and we distribute x to get these two terms.
Next we combine 2 and 4 10ths x, and 2 and 4 10ths x to get 4 and 8 10ths times
x. Now to clear these decimals, I'm going to go ahead and multiply through by a
factor of 10. When we multiply through by 10, we'll get 48x48 8, 10x squared,
and 20x. Now we're ready to move these two terms, to the right hand side of our
equation, so we can get 0 on the left side, and a quadratic expression on the
right hand side. Now, we're ready to divide this equation by 2 since all these
coefficients are even. When we divide each of these terms by 2, we'll get this
new equation. Now we can factor. When we use factoring by grouping, we get the
factors 5x plus 6 and x minus 4. We set each factor equal to 0 and then we can
solve for the values of X. X can equal positive 4 or X can equal negative 6
fifths. We know X to the amount of time it takes for Carlos to edit the film.
So, it would take him 4 hours we don't use this choice since it's negative.
That wouldn't make sense with our concept of time. So, since it takes Carlos 4
hours, it must take Melissa 6 hours. We know this is true since x was 4, which
is the amount of time it takes Carlos. And Melissa was X plus 2, two more hours
than Carlos. If you are ever unsure, go back to the original problem. We knew
Carlos time was represented by X, so he would take four hours to edit the film.
Melissa takes two hours longer than Carlos so that means that she needs six
hours in order to edit the film. I know this one was tough, so great work if
you got it right.